[Music]
all right let's go to zach in huntsville
texas north of where i grew up what's up
zach
uh not much hauling freight
hauling freight that's what i'm talking
about way to go zach hey
while you're at it fix the supply chain
dude what are you doing
uh i'm
i'm just hauling stuff i just hold
whatever they tell me right
i see you passing the book hey i'm
grateful for the call brother what's up
how can i help
alrighty so uh my father passed away
back in september
and i'm sorry what from what man i'm
sorry um
i'm not exactly sure there was a couple
of diagnoses i think it boiled down to
mainly some type of blood infection
he fought it for well over a year and a
half and
around september he finally just said
i'm sorry i can't like he even asked the
pastor if it was like against
against his face to like just admit he
doesn't have a fight anymore and he
uh passed away
so i'm sorry man how old are you
i'm 28. dang man i'm sorry brother
that's hard man
i appreciate it um
the main reason for the call though is
i'm the oldest of four i'm the oldest of
four boys i got three younger siblings
okay
my youngest brother is 15
and he seemed to be having the toughest
time with it
i don't remember i cannot for the life i
may remember how he phrased it but he
was helping with taking care of my dad
when he was having
like when some of this was going on
like he said something that hinted to
the idea that he thinks he's the reason
dad didn't get better that's exactly
right
yep and um
i'm trying to navigate how me and my
brothers can help him out okay
and also how i can
how i can talk to my mom about certain
things that happen because
there's a couple issues number one she
gets defensive if i
ask if we can send him to counseling and
she has also
she also gets defensive if i ask for
like help with what do you want me to do
when he's having because like one of the
reasons that prompted the call is he's
having major attitude outbursts and i
don't know how to handle it my mom gets
to me anytime i
try to do something about it and i
cannot i've asked her every which way
and i cannot get her to like talk to me
it's like what boundaries do you want me
to set to get him to not have attitudes
with me and how to help him i'm not
trying to be a jerk or anything i'm
trying to be his brother and love him
but right i can't handle it if you're
going to yell at me for everything i do
and i
you got to give me something yeah yeah
absolutely man well again i'm sorry i'm
sorry for the loss of your dad that's
hard man whether you're 28 58 68 or 15.
it's brutal all right
um
so i'll i'll walk you through a few
things here and i just want to start by
saying your brother's lucky to have you
in his life
um we're gonna i want you to
listen carefully we're gonna reorient a
few things and um
hopefully i can provide some wisdom for
you okay the first thing is i want you
to keep this in your head this line
our childhood biography becomes our
adult biology
our childhood biography becomes our
adult biology
so
uh right when you said my brother was
helpful help helping take care of my dad
i wrote down the words if he hid only
dot dot dot
and you you immediately followed that up
with right what i wrote down with now
he's starting to blame himself which is
exactly what happens
when kids are
brought in and let's i don't want to i
know your kid's brother's 15 he's
probably a big guy whatev he's a kid
he's a child okay
and when kids are given the
responsibility of making sure their
parents are okay physically emotionally
psychologically spiritually whatever
kids aren't strong enough to carry that
and when it inevitably goes sideways
which it always does anytime a kid is
having to prop up a parent then the kid
immediately goes what did i do or i
should have done this thing if i had
only done this thing then this would
have happened this would have been okay
and if we don't get on that right now he
will try to solve for that failure that
perceived failure that's not even real
for the rest of his life and his body
will pay the toll his relationships will
pay the toll and these outbursts is his
body trying to work that out right now
while we're in it he's in the middle of
hard grief and it doesn't sound like
he's getting a good picture of what
grieving should look like from your mom
is that fair
yeah yeah that's very fair i
i don't know exactly what caused this my
mom's the person she don't really
like she cried at the funeral and my
brothers took a turn giving her hug and
stuff like that but 90 of her grieving
has been done alone in her room that's
right so
as a bit of an issue for this that i
think might help her if he got any
advice on this as to how to approach her
about it but my aunt wayne d passed away
five years ago i want to say and she was
the closest person to my mother she was
the only person aside from my dad that
she would ever break down emotionally in
front of and she's not found another
best friend since then um okay and
and even then she was a family member
not a best friend right
uh technically look
we call her aunt wendy because she's
been in our life for 10 years our next
door neighbors we were very close to
them
not related but
you know what i mean actually yeah i've
got several folks who call me uncle john
and same thing and they're not i'm not
related to them but just been there in
their lives to their kids so yeah i
totally get that
um okay oh crap i actually just forgot
about this um maya wendy's husband
randy uh
adopted uncle
okay probably the most positive male
influence in all of my brother's lives i
forgot to mention this he passed away a
month before my dad died oh jeez okay
yeah that's big too so it's just a lot
of trauma a lot of loss
all right so
man
couple things here one there's you and i
could probably talk for a few hours
about mom
and
there's not a lot you can do about mom
you just can't
and i would also
i'd cut her as much grace and slack as
you possibly can
she also has that same if i had only
been able to going through her body and
head too
if i just cared this way or if or maybe
she's pissed off that he quote unquote
quit on her right he quit fighting for
me right
and grief makes us do really gnarly
things like make the whole situation
about ourselves because we're scared
we're alone suddenly we're exposed
so when it gets to your brother
understand that your brother is taking
his cues on what should come next how he
should feel what's okay what's not okay
from the grown-ups in his life
and he's not getting a good one from his
mom right now
and what he really really needs from his
big brother is not another father
he needs a brother
okay
and it's tempting for you to come in and
be the i'm the man of the house now and
you don't talk like that that kind of
dad
stuff brothers do things a little bit
differently right and brothers can say
things a little bit differently that
dads can't say brothers are
able to bypass things the dads you know
dad's got to keep some decorum and
nonsense like that which is just part of
being a dad i got it too but brothers
can
come around some of that so i want you
to keep in your mind i'm gonna be his
brother not his dad okay and that's
gonna be different lectures that's gonna
be different the way just a just a
posture and you've probably felt like
his dad for a long time because the aide
you have such a big age gap right
dude
to an extent yeah like i've never like
took i never
like
thought of it as like dad but
like
i messaged my brothers to let them know
i was calling to see if they had any
questions one of the things my brother
mentioned he's like he thinks i still
view his as a child and jokingly he's
not totally wrong but even still
jokingly i was like well of course i do
he's my baby brother i'm 12 years older
than him
so i want you to elevate him because he
grew up real fast
okay he's a child
who's had adult experiences now
and his body's gonna rattle for a while
trying to
toggle back and forth between that okay
so
here's what he needs
like
asap are y'all in the same community in
the same neighborhood
uh no i live in texas they live in
colorado okay
he needs somebody
does he have any any brothers and
sisters around him in colorado
um
the brother under me lives about three
hours away in denver and he regularly
communicates and tries to help out with
some of these things and then my brother
his wife and his children live with my
mom like that they're kind of like
sharing a house are they stable
yeah they're stable so he needs a
brother who can take him out once a week
just them too
and he needs adults in his life talking
to him about how much they're hurting
and this sounds counterintuitive and
backwards like we need to go to the back
room and hide our grief we cry when no
one's watching
because we don't want to hurt little
brother and you're stealing from little
brother you're making little brother
feel crazy
so he needs to know that you're weeping
that you're devastated that you're
heartbroken
that you you think in your head i should
have done more even though that's that's
nuts
he's desperate for that from y'all all
of y'all but he needs somebody to take
him out every week and just be a human
with him and what you can do from from
nine hours away like you or ten hours
away like you are
is you can
this is gonna sound so lame dude i'm
just telling you you can become pen pals
with him y'all can you can write him a
letter once a week and you just commit
to doing this which by the way you're
hurting too you've gone into fix-it mode
which is what 30-year-old guys do but
you're hurting too
and
whether it's on email whether it's i'd
prefer it to be handwritten but email
will do in a pinch
a weekly phone call with him just to say
hey i'm this week sucks how are you
and he needs to know oh my gosh my big
brother is is struggling
and
it i'm not crazy
you hear what i'm saying
his body has had two important male role
models just pulled right out from under
him and now he's gonna fill the gap with
outburst and chaos and whatever is going
to make this pain stop hurting
and like i said he's going to be on a
sideways track if somebody doesn't step
in there real quick
um
if the adults in his life aren't buying
this are grieving badly this ends not
well for him that's what i'll tell you
so when it comes to you you need to have
a hard conversation with your brother
that lives there with your sister-in-law
that lives there
and cut mom some slack
i would tell you at the end of the day
if he starts showing signs of he's
getting into drugs he's disappearing
he's staying alone all the time then i
would reach out and call a school
counselor i'd go around mom
and say i'm worried about my brother my
mom's dealing with her own grief in a
heavy heavy way in fact you know what
i'm gonna alter what i just said i think
y'all should call him call the school
counselor anyway
and let them know this has happened
and my mom's struggling with grief we
just want to let you know there's no
abuse or anything nobody's getting hurt
but i wanted this on y'all's radar he
needs some extra attention and some
extra care right now he needs some extra
adults in his life telling him he loves
them and i'm all the way here in texas i
just wanted to reach out with all the
resources we got
i would do that today probably make that
phone call today
um
and the counselor will reach out and
he'll probably be like no i'm cool man
i'm fun i'm cool
and i want you to let the counselor know
he's not he's not okay and he's holding
a lot of this in on himself and if
you'll check on him that'd be great and
the counselor will know in short order
if
he needs to be referred to psychological
services and things like that uh but i
think that'd be a gift but man if your
brother who's living with him right now
could just say hey once a week we're
going to get something to eat just the
two of us i'm checking in with you if
your brother who lives with him would or
your sister-in-law with him
would get one of those you've heard me
talk about this on the show would get a
journal that just sits on his bed that
he will write in every day and then drop
it back off on their bed and they can
just have some sort of dialogue even if
it just says the entry for february you
know 29th today sucked that's it
that's it
or
not doing okay today was okay
miss dad
those little bitty things it's a it's a
it's a it's oxygen it's just a little
breath of air little breath air a little
breath of air and
my big concern moving forward is mom is
gonna start to vampire everybody
and that she's gonna need people to take
care of her and he's gonna end up in
that role too
is that am i on to that or no
i'm
that's the tough that's a tough one to
figure out because my mom like despite
the fact that she's kind of hiding most
of her grief she's still a really strong
woman she's put up with a lot throughout
the years and she does her best to
take care of the family he needs to hear
that that's the mercy i give her is i
know that when she gets mad at me for
questioning like how do i deal with it
when he's doing this and stuff like that
she's trying to love him she's good well
but when you ask her that question
you're you're it's an indictment on her
parenting
and yeah she doesn't take that
if she's carrying around that somehow i
failed my husband and that's why he's
dead which is irrational but that
happens a lot
that's like we just naturally go into
what could i have done
and then her oldest son calls and he's
like yeah and what about this 15 year
old too i mean then you see what i'm
saying like that that ends up being a
heavy load
i'd rather you call him
and say not hey you need to shut your
mouth not that that's dad
hey man i heard you're really struggling
brother how's it going and if he's like
i'm not struggling be like dude i hear
how you're talking you're not doing okay
right so we're going at it like a
brother we're going at it with
hey man i'm this hurts
and you as big brother need to go first
and let him know i'm not okay you need
to go first and let him know hey by the
way your job is to love you as much as
you love dad right now
you need to turn the screens off get out
in nature make sure you're moving around
make sure you're going to lunches and
breakfasts and things like that
you need to make sure you're writing
this stuff down mail it to me i'll mail
you it back what i'm writing back to you
he needs to have some permission
to begin to take care of him taking care
of himself in the way that he's been
taking care of his dad for so long and
again all that permission has to be said
explicitly
by an adult that he cares about and who
loves him and that he knows loves them
and that's you
so know him hawing it has to be
hey your job is not to take care of mom
that's not your job
she's an adult your job is to love and
take care of you
i'm gonna send you a letter every single
week your job is to write me back
older brother who lives with him you
have to come eat with me that's just two
brother rules it's just the rule it's
gonna make it happen and on and on and
on
he's so blessed to have you in his life
but hear me say
you all got to get on him now and he
doesn't need a bunch of answers he needs
a bunch of connection
not a lot of answers a lot a lot of
connection